ouais si l'auteur
avant
talent voilà alors ils détiennent une
carte une carte de quoi perdre deux
beaux gosses
ah oui hier google voit très bien ça
commence un peu plus ça va bien donc
après ma femme est une actrice dont nous
avons dit si le plus grand bien
vous sortez ils ont atteint le 25 août
votre deuxième film ils se marièrent et
eurent beaucoup d'enfants avec charlotte
gainsbourg
emmanuelle seigner alain chabat à un
cohen le petit garçon du vieil homme et
l'enfant qui revient johnny depp
tu reviens aussi parce qu'il était dans
le creux de la main c'est ce qu'on
disait un musée à tout à l'heure il a
pris du bide eu la grosse île et ils
devraient surveiller le johnny depp
anouk aimée claude berri et vous voilà
alors le pitch il ya un pitch normal
qu'ils seraient c'est une comédie sur la
difficulté de rester en couple
et puis à mon pitch à moi c'est le
mariage c'est l'enfer
le célibat c'est l'enfer l'adultère
souffert et c'est vraiment ça plombe
bien total
et quand tu vois le film tu sors de là
c'est paniquer non non tu dises que
c'est une comédie derrière tout est
différent mais ceci c'est l'idée l'idée
c'était de traiter légèrement mais c'est
vrai que ça raconte ça comme on dit
c'est pas gai du tout l'histoire
alors vous le traitez très bien et d'une
façon très sympathique mais quand même
tout et l'enfer quand tu sais acacia bat
il est marié avec emmanuelle seigner qui
le martyrisent yarakh qu elle lui alors
lui c'est le célibataire que tard
mais toute façon se termine très mal
pour lui et il est planté à la fin et
puis à vous alors il ya chaque jour du
ce extraordinaire et ça ça m'a beaucoup
touché dans le titre circle donc notre
ami yvan trompe
charlotte gainsbourg est alors ils ont
un truc avec charlotte gainsbourg c'est
qu'ils aiment bien s'asperger que de
l'eau et à un moment vous asperger la
maîtresse est la maîtresse n'apprécie
pas et là on voit en comprend c'est
vachement de subtiles on comprend qu'à
ce moment là vous vous dites je préfère
ma femme ça c'est très fort c'est vrai
le prend pas bien mais avec ça c'est
vrai qu'elle sera mieux pour tout le
monde 21 leproux va bien
c'est pour cela qu'avec
j'ai un galet
comme avant
voilà
c'est moi c'est moins choquant voire 10
pour
toujours bien en voilà
donc voilà donc toujours forte
tout le monde a bien compris c'est la
dernière je crois que c'est la dernière
et vous aussi chez vous et du confort
seca 7,7 soit comme ça on est exactement
dans le film d'yves en fait le à la
maison et injuste il est tous avec toi
non non non non non jean reno mineurs
charlatans
beaucoup d'eau
et donc malheureusement avec la
maîtresse ça ne marche pas et là dans ce
qu'on sent bien yvan charade
j'ai ce que vous avez peur j'ai regardé
la caméra où il ya le rouge
et vous allez dire magnéto serge et par
l'ensemble se sécher au soleil avec les
micros manitoba